Okay,
so there was a couple of things that I
wanted to tell you
that were left open in the last lecture.
The first one was that I told you that
there were two types of games and then I
only told you about one type of games,
so I know you've all been dying of
curiosity about that ever since.
So the first type of game that we talked
about was the one where everyone has a
particularly shared goal.
You might think of that as a structured
game,
but the second type of game that Piaget
was interested in was a dramatic or
pretend play games.
And generally how a pretend play episode
works is that um,
while our child can all always do this
by him or herself,
but if it's a group game,
usually what happens is the kids get
together a little group and they
basically script out a little plane and
it's like,
it's like um,
what you call it,
spontaneous improvisation,
you know.
And so maybe they'll play house and then
they assign,
you know,
a,
a player to each role.
And I guess that would normally be
mother and father and baby often and
maybe pet dog or cat,
so you know you can be the cat and you
can be the mom and you can be the day I
didn't.
Then they'll set up a little dramatic
arena and maybe it's you know,
like a cable covered with blankets which
kids seem to particularly like.
And then they'll run through the game
now and in some sense what they're doing
is imitating their parents or maybe
their pat or maybe the baby,
but it's not exactly imitation.
And,
and this is an important thing to note
because imitation would imply if you're
imitating someone,
what your incense doing is duplicating
what they just did.
Now there are robots for example.
Now if you want to teach the robot how
to do something.
So maybe the robots got an arm.
In fact it does.
You can grab it's arm and you can go
like this.
And then as long as you put a cam there,
the robot will do exactly that precisely
that.
So your teaching,
if it has the capability of imitating
movements that it's already done once.
But you know,
when you're a kid and you're playing
house and maybe you're being the mother,
you don't precisely duplicate with your
body exactly the movements that you saw
your mother make,
maybe the last time you saw her or the
last time you were watching her.
What did you seem to be able to do
instead is to watch your mother over
long periods of time and extract out
something that you might describe as her
spirit.
And I know that that's not really a
psychological or a scientific word,
but it's a useful word because.
Or You could perhaps say her
personality,
but it's not her personality.
Exactly because it's her personality as
mother,
which isn't really her personality.
It's the mother personality and that
mother personality is something that has
been practiced by mothers for who knows
how long and what the child seems to do
when she will say for this example is
watching her mother,
is extract out what the spirit of
motherhood is and then embody that.
Right?
And so you might think of this spirit of
motherhood as those elements of behavior
and perception and emotion and cognition
for that matter.
But it's an,
it's an embodied,
all of those embodied simultaneously
what's in common across all the
instances of acting like a mother,
you know,
so you could say,
well that's mother like behavior and who
knows what that might be.
I mean,
what you want to do is conjure up the
stereotype,
roughly speaking of a mother,
you know,
people don't really like stereotypes,
especially in psychology,
but almost all your thinking is in
stereotypes.
So there's not much difference between
the stereotype and a category or
categories are oversimplifications and
so our stereotypes.
But anyways,
so you take management the stereotype of
a mother and then the child is acting
that out and what they're trying to do
is to become the mother roughly
speaking.
So,
and why?
Well,
for obvious reasons,
there's obvious reasons why someone
would do that.
It's because without mothers,
there wouldn't be any human beings.
And so if we didn't have successful
mothers then that would be the end of
us.
And so we wouldn't be here to talk about
it so that now one of the things that
piaget observed was this kind of
dramatic play was extraordinarily
important to children because it,
it helped them learn how to act like
they would act maybe when they're older
children or maybe when they're teenagers
or maybe when they're young adults.
It's a trial run in a relatively safe
environment.
One of the things I'd be thinking about,
it's not that easy to precisely specify
the role of a father,
but I really believe that one of the
things that fathers do,
if they do a good job being fathers,
is that they circumscribe a safe space
within the house or within the familial
environment where the children can play
free of interference.
And so then because play is also a very
sensitive behavior,
but by which I mean that
it's easy to disrupt play in children.
If there's anything wrong with the
child,
they won't play.
So one of the ways that you can tell if
your child is doing well is that they're
playing.
I mean,
I suppose you could say the same thing
about your dog or maybe even your
partner,
you know,
if they're in a playful mood than
perhaps there isn't anything
particularly wrong with the relationship
at the moment on all their,
all the needs that might be regarded as
in some sense more fundamental have been
met and so to get children to play well
you have to circumscribe a safe area and
they have to be taken care of and then
they can experiment with different modes
of Ba and they do that by themselves,
but they also do that in the company of
other children and obviously what
they're doing is practicing for later
roles and you know,
you see this sort of thing and children
at multiple levels because not only will
they play out being a parent,
that's a very common element of child's
play,
but they'll also often develop sort of
fixations on slightly older children,
maybe a year older or two,
two years older and sort of hero worship
that worship them and follow them around
and,
and imitate them even more directly than
they might imitate a parrot.
Now,
obviously the child has his or her
reasons for that and the reasons are,
is they're trying to advance to the next
stage so they scan the environment,
look for someone who seems to have done
that well,
whatever that means,
um,
who looks competent and has maybe
friendly and who could tolerate having a
kid trailed along behind them and then
they,
they act them out and so play all the
forms of play that we described.
The two basic forms are extremely
important to children and when you see
them pretending it as a parent,
one of the things that you should
realize is that it's an extraordinarily
important form of activity.
It's how they socialize themselves.
Now,
the other thing that I didn't mention,
this is going,
this is concentrating on piaget as well.
As you know,
we talked a little bit in the
mythological and shamanic initiation
lectures about the idea that human
personality evolution is a punctuated
upward development.
So he moved ahead and then you encounter
something that gets in your way,
some sort of severe obstacle and it
either blocks you behaviorally so that
you can't get to your goal using your
current behavioral plans or it's even
more complex than that and it disrupts
the whole structure that you're using to
integrate your behavior across time.
You know?
So the difference between that would
roughly be the difference between say
going home to your partner or going on a
date with your partner suit me.
People still do such things are going
out with your partner and them being in
an irritable mood.
And so what that would mean is that
maybe you smile at them or you tell them
a joke and you know it falls flat or
they responded in an angry manner and so
you're going to orient to that.
It's going to make things fall apart a
little bit.
You might say,
oh,
the whole night's ruined.
You probably don't say the whole
relationship has had it,
but if that happens enough times,
you might.
But you might say,
oh,
the whole night's ruined.
Or maybe you'll.
Which is probably a bit of an
overreaction right off the bat.
Like my impression as a clinician is
that when people are being difficult to
get along with,
you should let them do it three times
while you track it because then the
third time they do it,
you can say,
look,
you've done this,
here's what you're doing.
And I said,
no,
I'm not doing that.
And you say hi.
Yes you are because I saw you do it then
and then and then,
and then they're basically screwed.
You win right away if you do that.
So,
but more,
more seriously.
If it's just one little episode,
it's best to let it go.
You don't really have any proof and
maybe there's just some,
you know,
local thing wrong three times.
That's a whole different issue because
then you've got some credibility and
it's a nice balance between being too
impulsively reactive,
you know,
because you should stand up for
yourself.
Right?
Well,
does that mean that you should respond
to every little slight while you're
going to be reacting all the time if you
do that,
but you don't want to be a pushover and
let people walk all over you so you have
to find some balance between being
tolerant so you don't have unnecessary
fights and being tough so that you don't
have unnecessary fights and three is a
nice number anyways,
so you're with your partner and they're
being annoying and you know you can
reconstruct your behavior.
Maybe instead of telling jokes,
you look at your phone and let them calm
down or something like that.
You haven't disrupted much of the frame
that you're using to interact with them
right?
The night the evening is still
continuing in its planned manner.
You can still use the perceptual
structures and the expectations that
were guiding you.
They're modified at a very high
resolution minor level and then so
that's going to upset you a little bit
because you're going to think,
you know what's going on here.
Maybe you'll think,
is there something wrong with me or are
you going to.
If you're self conscious will do that or
maybe you'll think that there's
something wrong with them,
whatever,
but it's not that serious,
but then you know,
maybe you go on a,
you,
you're out with your partner and uh,
you know,
some person wanders over your
restaurants,
a person wanders over to the table and
says hello to your partner.
I didn't know that you had a girlfriend
or boyfriend,
you know,
you didn't tell me that when we went out
last week.
Well,
that's going to be a whole different
scenario,
right?
Yeah.
And you all laugh about that because you
know perfectly well that it's a
different scenario.
Right?
And you might say,
well,
why is the one scenario more disrupting
than the other?
An answer to that is something like
if your presuppositions about the world
are arranged in a hierarchy in a sense,
so that the little actions that you take
to do something or at the very bottom of
the hierarchy,
they're the micro details and then you
continue to abstract art all the way to
the top,
which might be,
I'm in a committed relationship now.
There's levels of hierarchy going from
being in a committed relationship to the
little options that you undertake with
one another.
The higher up you you have to go in the
hierarchy,
the higher up the disruption occurs in
the hierarchical level,
the more upset you're going to beat.
So irritable partner,
well,
you can sort of walk around that
unfaithful partner.
Well,
you know,
that's pretty much up at the top of the
hierarchy where you have to start
rethinking your past and your present
and your future and maybe who you are
and who they are and who men are and who
women are.
And it's like,
it's,
uh,
it's really,
it's a disaster,
right?
Everything falls apart.
Well then that's the little trip to the
underworld that we talked about.
Now Piaget had an idea like that also
with regards to children because his
stage theory is a punctuated theory.
One of the things he noted about
children with that was that they would
construct a structure and a structure
would be.
I think,
again,
the best way to think about it as,
as a personality,
because the personality has thoughts and
emotions and motivations and action.
So all of those at the same time,
it's this little alive sub element of
view and the children's children are
conjuring up these little sub elements
of themselves that have functional
utility as they build themselves from
the,
from the,
from their motor systems upwards and
now,
and then they run into a situation where
the
tools that they've built,
the subpersonalities that they built
aren't fulfilling the desired function.
So maybe that'll happen when,
um,
you know,
a three year old goes to kindergarten
and isn't making friends easily.
While that's going to be a child would
come home after that cry,
fall apart,
and maybe be angry and tell their
parents,
no one would play with me.
And you know,
they'll break down,
they'll have tears.
And it's almost as if they switch from a
domain where they're competent.
Like emotions signifies,
especially negative emotions signifies
that you've moved from the domain in
which you're competent to the domain in
which you're not competent.
And if you're crying,
for example,
then that's often a distress signal,
sometimes it's anger,
but it's often a distress signal and it
means I've,
I've ended up in a situation where what
I know is no longer sufficient to
produce the outcomes that I desire.
So you cry and then you get help people
come and say,
well,
what's the matter?
And they give you a little pat and you
know,
and they console you and then maybe they
help you strategize about what you could
do to make the situation better or how
you could act or if you're a smart
parent,
maybe you play with your child and
offered them upgrade their ability to
interact socially.
Or you can take them out on additional
play dates or whatever and monitor their
behavior and help them reconstruct their
little subpersonalities.
So,
and bring in more information so that
it's more sophisticated.
And so that would be the phd.
So this is a combination of the PSW and
ideas of this stage theory,
which is movement upward with a
punctuation.
That's the confusion because the
previous structure is no longer well
adapted to the world.
And then the idea of assimilation and
accommodation,
psj kind of made assimilation and
accommodation in a sense opposites and
it's not exact,
it's hard to figure out,
but assimilation for piaget is when you
pull information in and the structure,
the internal structure that you're
pulling it into doesn't really have to
change that much.
And accommodation is when you pull in a
fairly mighty piece of information,
often negative and it's so disruptive
that the structure that you're using to
understand the information has to be
reconstructed.
Now psj thinks of assimilation or
accommodation,
but I think it's much easier to think
about it on a continuum with the
assimilation occurring at the level of
micro behaviors.
You know,
like if you,
if you're trying to pick up a fork,
you know,
maybe your hands when you try to pick up
a fork and it doesn't work a couple of
times,
then you just change your grip and pick
it up.
Like it's a little annoying.
You're going to look at the fork and
you're going to try a couple of routines
to pick it up.
But you know,
it's not going to bring your whole damn
world to a halt,
you know,
so whereas if you find a dead mouse in
your soup,
well that's going to be a whole
different story.
And again,
it's a hierarchical issue.
And so at the bottom near the motor
structures,
I would say it's easy to assimilate.
You just have to make minor changes to
the.
I like to think about them as maps
really,
but their maps or personalities that no,
those don't sound the same,
but they're very similar.
Depends on whether the thing needs a
little adjustment or whether you have to
toss the whole thing away and build a
new one.
You know,
it's the difference between tightening
the lug nuts on your car,
buying a new car.
You can see levels of.
You can understand it as levels of
difficulty.
Another way of thinking about it,
you need to know this because you need
to understand how it is that you figure
out how upset you should get when
something goes wrong.
It's a very,
very complicated question.
If you wake up with is an ache in your
side,
how upset should you be?
Well,
you don't know.
It's like maybe it's nothing.
Maybe you're going to die of cancer in
six months.
You don't know,
and so it's not self evident how people
calibrate their emotions when something
goes wrong because of the extent of the
thing that went wrong is not clearly
evident.
Your partner's crabby when you out for
dinner,
does that mean that you're going to
break up in two weeks?
While it might mean that,
so why don't you just flip out right
away because the whole world's coming to
an end.
Well,
some people do,
right?
And those would be people who were
higher in negative emotion.
They're hire and neuroticism because
they're more likely to react as if a
small,
potentially small anomaly or uncertainty
or threat or discontinuity or unexpected
occurrence is catastrophic.
We're an emotionally stable person.
You know,
you might really have,
you might have to say,
I'm breaking up with you before.
They're going to know,
look upset,
and maybe even then it's not going to
bother them that much.
So.
So you think of the motor hierarchy,
you know,
ranging from micro behaviors at the
bottom to abstractions at the top,
and then you can understand how you
might compute how upset you get when
something goes wrong.
Assume that it's small to begin with.
Check at that level.
If you can't fix it at that level,
advanced one level up.
If your car doesn't work,
you don't buy a new one.
The first thing you do is maybe see if
the battery is dead right?
Because that that's the path that you
could take that would cause you the
least amount of trouble and to really
good
schema for mental hygiene.
It's like Ockham's,
razor,
you know,
Ockham's,
razor and science,
right?
Does that make.
Does everybody know what Ockham's razor
is?
How many people know how,
what Ockham's razor is?
Okay.
How many people don't know?
Oh,
that's amazing.
It's amazing.
That's okay.
Well,
you should know.
It's really too bad that you don't know.
It's undoubtedly no reflection on you.
Anyways.
Arcoms razor is the,
is the phrase referring to a
what?
A principal that was established by an
ancient thinker,
Arcam and he said,
do not multiply your explanatory
principles beyond necessity.
Okay,
and so what he meant was if you have six
reasons why something might have gone
wrong and you can rank,
order them in terms of complexity,
pick the simplest one and then until you
disproved that,
stick with it and then go to the next
simplest one and so on,
so and it's often used as a guiding
principle in science where the where the
idea is
if you have a simple explanation,
don't complicate it up with a bunch of
unnecessary assumptions and you also
might be reflective of a deeper
underlying truth,
which is that
it's unlikely for any set of entities to
be in any particular configuration,
but it's particularly unlikely for them
to be an a not unlikely and complex
configuration.
So anyways,
and so hopefully that's understandable.
You can tangle all those ideas together
at the bottom of your personality
hierarchy.
There are actions at the top.
There are abstractions.
Moral abstractions like be a good
person.
When you run into something that's
unexpected,
the amount you get upset is
proportionate to the level in the
hierarchy where the damage appears to be
taking place.
Now you kind of have to guess it,
that partner,
you do that with your temperament,
so if you're high in neuroticism,
you guessed catastrophe and if it's low
in neuroticism,
you guess irrelevant and you do that
partly because of the way that you
perceive your own competence.
You know,
because if you've encountered minor to
major problems in the past,
say even if you're a nervous person and
you've solved them,
you might've learned while,
yeah,
it's a problem,
but I can fix problems so it's not
really a problem.
Which is a really good way to think of
yourself.
You know,
that's a better way,
a much better way to think of yourself
that I'm a person with no problems.
It's like,
good luck with that,
but I'm a person who could successfully
address problems if I concentrated on
that.
That's very,
very useful.
And then the other way that your nervous
system sort of decides how upset you
should get when something happens is by
looking at how other people treat you.
And if they treat you like you're
competent,
then your nervous system gets less
neurotic.
That that's a good way of thinking about
you produce more Serotonin,
you react less globally to indications
of error.
Okay.
So anyway,
so piaget,
he talks about assimilation.
Assimilation is when you have to make a
little change in accommodation is when
the whole damn structure has to be
reconfigured.
And he thought about those in some sense
as separate types of learning,
but they're not.
They're on a,
they're on a continuum from very simple
to very complex.
Have any of you ever heard of the idea
of a paradigm shift?
How many people have heard of that?
Okay.
How many people haven't.
Alright,
do you know the name Thomas Kuhn?
Anybody?
No.
Okay.
Well Thomas Kuhn was a philosopher of
science and he wrote a book in 1962
called,
um,
scientific.
Is that what it's called?
The nature of scientific revolutions?
Yeah.
And coon basically said the same thing
about the way knowledge structures
proceeded,
as Piaget said,
about that progression of knowledge
structures within the individual.
So going with concerned about large
scale transformations in scientific
viewpoint.
So let me give you an example.
So in the late eighties and nineties,
physicists were convinced that they're
just going to have to shut the whole
endeavor down.
Why?
Well,
because the physicists knew everything
there was to know there wasn't a single
phenomena at that point that physicists
could not account for it except one.
And here's the one that they couldn't
account for it.
So imagine you're on a train and it's
going that way at half the speed of
light and you shine a
flashlight,
you're standing on the top of the trade,
obviously protecting yourself against
the wind.
And you shine a light going ahead and
you measure the speed of light out of
your flashlight.
The speed of light is 186,000 miles per
second out of your flashlight.
Okay?
So now you're on,
you're on the ground and you're watching
this train zip by and the guys on top of
it shining a flashlight and light comes
out of the front of his flashlight and
you measured the speed of it.
What's the speed?
While you might think,
well obviously it's the speed of light
plus half the speed of light because the
train is going half the speed of light
and the light is going the speed of
light,
and so the light coming from the
combination of the train and the light
is this is the speed of light plus half
the speed of light.
That's what would happen if someone was
throwing the ball right,
but that isn't right.
What happens is it's the speed of light
and no matter how fast you're going,
when you shine your flashlight out,
the light coming out of your flashlight,
he's going to be going exactly 186,000
miles an hour,
minute second,
sorry,
hundred 80,
6,000 miles a second.
It's not additive and so if you're.
If you're on the train and you're
backwards and you're shining your light
and the person meshes,
it's not the speed of light minus half
the speed of light,
which is what it would be if you were
throwing the ball.
It's speed of light.
Well,
nobody knew how the hell to account for
that.
It's like that just made no sense at
all,
but everyone was ignoring it.
Well,
it turns out you can ignore that and
that wasn't the only thing that wasn't
quite well laid out at the end of the
19th century from the perspective of
physics,
but it was a big one,
and to solve that Newtonian physics had
to be completely overthrown and quantum
physics put in its place and quantum
physics is quantum physics.
You might think of it as a box like this
and inside that there's a box that says
Newtonian physics and quantum physics
can explain everything that Newtonian
physics can explain,
but it explains some more things besides
and so you would say because of that,
it's a better theory.
Now I might say,
well,
you just made a personality
transformation.
Are you better person than you were
before?
And you might say,
well,
how in the world can you make a judgment
like that?
And I would say,
well,
if you're a better personality,
you could do all the things you could do
before just as well or maybe even a
little better.
Plus there's a bunch of new things that
you can do that's a better personality.
So another interesting example of how
the idea of better,
which really is a moral idea in some
sense,
better versus worse,
you can conceptualize it,
but this is one of the things that
piaget is really,
really useful because it gives you a,
a language that's grounded in
observation and in science to start to
handle questions that start to border on
the moral.
So a better personality can do more than
the previous personality could and you
can certainly see how that would be
applicable to your life.
And one of the things I would suggest as
a consequence of that is,
you know,
people always compare themselves to
other people and generally what you do
is you compare yourself.
You make a little dominance hierarchy
out of the people that are right around
you and this is a very annoying
propensity because what it means is that
no matter how successful you get in your
life,
you're still going to be in the middle
of the dominance hierarchy.
So you'll end up,
I dunno,
maybe you end up,
God,
I don't know.
Maybe you're CEO of a $100,000,000
company.
Let's say,
well,
I'll get to go hang out with a bunch of
ceos and like there's 10 of them.
Three of them are ceos of a $2,000,000
company.
It's like you're a pretty little CEO
among those people,
but who are you going to be comparing
yourself to?
The guys who pick up your trash?
It's like,
no,
you could,
but you won't.
You'll have your little group around you
and you'll be somewhere in the middle,
and so that's useful to know because
that means that what you have to learn
to cope with is the fact that you're
going to be somewhere in the middle and
then you might say,
well,
how do you cope with that?
Because you should be improving and you
also want to be very good at something.
Well,
I think the best way to do that,
and this is especially true when you're
older,
is that you don't compare yourself to
other people.
You compare yourself to the previous
version of you.
It's a good control,
right?
Because you'll see,
especially by the time you were about 30
when you're young,
you have to compare yourself to other
people because
because when you're young,
you're a lot like all other young people
in some sense,
but by the time you're 30 year old or
you're not very much like other people
at all,
and so you know because the conditions
of your life start to become so unique
and specific to you.
Well then comparing yourself to other
people isn't very helpful,
but comparing yourself to who you were
before,
that's really helpful and you can keep
doing that your whole life and it's a
fair game.
Right?
Because the previous you had all the
problems and all the
like opportunities and and positive
attributes that you have.
It's fair.
It's a fair game and it'll.
It'll save you an awful lot of misery,
so alright,
so
the outline,
different forms of games and he talked
about different ways that those aided in
socialization and you can understand
that I used this Meta idea which was the
hierarchy of personality to sort of
explain that from a Piagetian
perspective.
You put yourself together from your body
upward towards increased abstractions
and as you do that you can do more
things with your body,
but you can also do more complex things.
Integrating those things that you do
with your body across time and with
increasing numbers of other people.
Now he actually has this really cool
idea about what constitutes morality as
a consequence of that.
So he would say,
all right,
so let's say
you can choose gay or you can choose
game be and you might say,
well I want to figure out whether they
may or gave me is a better game because
if I'm going to play a game,
it might as well be a better game.
And so he would say,
okay,
so here's how you can figure out if the
game you're playing is a good one.
Okay.
It's good for you now,
it's good for you now,
next week,
next month,
next year,
and 10 years from now.
So don't always a good for you now,
but if you play it repeatedly,
things get better for you.
Okay?
So that's,
that's a game where you're taking the
future into account.
It's not an impulsive game,
you know,
like if you wanna if cocaine is really,
really good for people for about a day,
but over a week or six months or five
years,
it's a degenerating game.
So,
and you can't use your emotion to
determine that because cocaine generally
suffuses the person who's using it with
a sense of power and possibility.
So you can't just rely on your emotion
no more than you can when you're tempted
to do something impulsive and fun,
but that might have negative
consequences.
Okay?
So the game should be good now and
across the future and then it should be
good for you and it should be good for
your family and it should be good for
your social community and so forth as
you spiral out word.
And it should be good for all of those
things across multiple expanses of time
and PSJ would call that an e rated game.
Now there's another additional idea
behind the idea of inequality rated
game,
which is that
if I'm playing a game that's good for me
and it's good for you and it's good for
you and it's good for you,
then we probably will all be willing to
play it voluntarily.
And so that's also why piaget believed
that in some sense a game like
structure,
let's say a social structure that
everybody plays because they want to is
much better than a game like structure
where everyone plays because they have
to.
And so he would say,
well that's in part the technical
difference between a tyranny and a
democracy.
It's a bloody smart thinking.
No,
I think Piaget got further with that
idea than anyone else had ever in
history because you can understand
there's this old idea.
Bob was hume,
another philosopher.
What's his first name?
What's that?
David?
Yes,
he took.
I can remember that.
David Hume.
He has this idea that you can derive
from.
It is.
So it's another one of those principles
like Arkansas Razor,
and what it means is something like
this,
no matter how much you know about
something,
that doesn't mean that you can figure
out what you should do about it.
So here's an example.
Let's say we know AIDS is a problem.
We know cancer is a problem.
We know heart disease is a problem,
we know poverty's a problem,
etc. There's all these problems.
How do you deTermine how you would
allocate resources to those different
problems?
Well,
it's a very,
very difficult problem to get out from a
scientific perspective.
And the reason for that is that,
well,
there's all these variables that you
would have to equate.
Imagine you built a spreadsheet and so
you were thinking,
okay,
which is the most trouble,
some of these things,
and then you know,
which could we solve with the least
amount of money?
While the problem is,
is that to to determine whether
something is troublesome,
you still have to make a value judgment.
Like tHere's no way you can get to the
bottom of the problem without
introducing the problem of value
judgment.
And that's partly why it's very
difficult to derive an ot.
What you should do from an is what you
know,
and that's why there's a distinction
between science and morality are science
and religion.
That's another way of thinking about it
is that they're there.
They're different domains.
Now,
piaget in some sense has described a way
out of that because he does say,
well,
look,
a theory that's better than the previous
theory is the theory that explains the
same amount plus more and you can apply
that to your personality and then a game
that's better than a different game is
one that benefits you and more people.
But it also does that over different
spans of time.
Now,
game like that's very hard to compute.
You know,
when people talk about environmental
sustainability,
what they're really talking about is a
pig,
eddie and equivalent of calibrated game
where you can live in your family and
your family can live in society and
society can operate within an economy
and the economy can exist within the
oncology without having it is the
economy tilt the ecology so that you
can't live and your family can't live in
your society,
can function on the act and the economic
system can't function.
So there is this idea of multilevel
ballots,
but those things are very,
very difficult to compute.
You know,
so,
but it's still a nice principle,
you know,
so if you're thinking,
well,
if you need a justification for what
you're doing and you want to put
yourself on from moral ground,
which is really useful because then
people can't push you around verbally or
intellectually or any other way because
you're,
you know,
you're grounded,
you're standing on something solid.
It's like you need to know why is this
good for you as if you were someone you
were taken care of.
Why is it good for you across a long
period of time?
HoW does it benefit your family,
how does it benefit society,
and then you know,
you can keep stepping upward from there.
So I could give you one example of
someone who's doing that.
I think you know about that.
That's kin who figured out how to get
plastic out of the oceans.
He's not just whining about it and you'd
like parading around with a sign that
says,
you know,
I don't like pollution.
It's like as if you need to tell people
that,
you know,
because everyone really doesn't like,
I don't like pollution and I'm against
poverty.
It's like,
yeah,
well find someone who's for pollution
and poverty.
Anyways,
this kid was about 17,
something like that,
and he was diving around.
He's a diver,
I think it was spear fishing and he
noticed there was more plastic than fish
and this wasn't a very happy discovery
for him.
And then so I started thinking about
that.
How can we get the plastic out of the
oceans?
And then he was looking at manta rays
and manta rays have these big wings that
help them sort of glide through the
ocean.
And he thought about that for awhile and
then he thought,
well maybe I could build this sort of
ray thing that lies on the surface of
the ocean in a triangle,
and then it could be towed through the
ocean and all the plastic would go to
the apex of the triangle and then you
can just scoop it up.
But then he did his calculations and I
haven't got this story quite right,
but this is basically,
this is basically the story.
He did some calculations and found out,
well that's not cost effective because
it takes a lot of energy to drag this
thing through the water and there's a
lot of water and you know,
and plus you're polluting like mad while
you're dragging this thing through the
water.
And so probably it's just not that
helpful.
But then he realized that if you go out
in the ocean,
there are these massive things called
gyres which are like,
they're like huge water hurricanes,
except they're very,
very,
very slow moving.
But they're huge.
They're continent size.
And so the oceans are already moving,
always moving.
So he thought hot,
since the ocean is moving,
there's no real reason to have to drag
the,
you know,
the plastic or the plastic gatherer
through the water.
You could just nail it to the ocean bed
with cables and then just have it sit
there and then the ocean would go
through it all by itself.
So he built A prototype which wasn't
very big and he gathered up a fair bit
of plastic,
all the plastics and the boat,
the foot of the ocean by the way.
And it really increases in density as
you move up towards the top bitch.
So then he built a bigger one and then
he got a bunch of.
He went on kickstarter and then he
raised a bunch of money and then he got
a bunch of engineers to look at his idea
and they said,
well,
you know,
this probably work.
So then they built a big one a couple of
kilometers long,
which is now in place off the shore of
Japan.
They also sent a whole flotilla of
people from California to who I do a
garbage estimate,
see how much garbage,
the risk of the water,
because there's a big spot in the middle
of the pacific called the great garbage
spot,
which is full of great plastic spot.
It doesn't matter.
It's full of plastic.
So they went to estimate how much there
was it in anyways.
He thinks he can guide this thing to the
bottom of the ocean and these big jars
make it,
you know,
100 kilometers long in a v shape,
put a kind of a collector at the end of
it,
load all the plastic he collects up on
barges,
go refine that into oil or plastic and
pay for it while he's doing it.
And so you can look them up.
Um,
and I think he's like 19 or 20 now.
So,
you know,
that's a good equilibrated game,
right?
That works out really well.
He gets to make some money.
Good for him.
He gets to employ a bunch of people.
That's a good thing.
Everybody's happy about it because it's
good.
You know,
we're getting rid of the garbage and
like there's no downside,
so it's hard to say.
It's hard to come up with an argument
for why that isn't a good thing and it's
good.
It's good because everyone benefits all
the way up.
So that's an equilibrated integrated
state.
It's a very,
very,
very smart idea.
Okay.
Now,
young
experimental psychologists don't like
you.
Well,
they don't like freud either and they
don't have much time for clinicians in
general,
but that's okay.
They're not trying to solve the same
problems.
Now usually if you take a personality
course,
you'll cover freud before you cover
young and the reason for that is that
freud in some ways preceded young
historically and lots of people,
especially the freudians like to think
of young as freud's student and there's
some truth to that because freud was the
first person who really collected up
ideas about the unconscious and
formalize them,
publicize them,
and applied them to the problems of
pathology and mental health.
So good for him.
And freud was unparalleled at describing
pathological families and there's plenty
of those,
but young was interested in something
that was underneath that.
I mean freud got underneath things a
lot,
you know,
he was also one of the first people to
point out just exactly how potent sexual
and aggressive motives were in shaping
the way that we thought,
but young
[inaudible] was more interested in some
sense,
young was more like a darwinian
biologist.
He was much more interested in the
biological and psychological,
philosophical history of fundamental
human behavioral patterns and so young
wasn't like a behaviorist can.
Behaviorist would think
when you're born,
there's nothing there except the
possibility to learn things.
You're a blank slate and then everything
you learned as a consequence of sensory
information that you're picking up and
what you learn as a consequence of that.
But young,
he didn't think that at all.
He thought that there's a specific human
nature and he set out to understand what
that human nature is.
Now,
a couple of lectures ago,
I talked to you about the characters
that you might imagine making up the
world that you inhabit.
So I said,
well,
you can think about the absolute
unknown,
which is the unknown,
that so unknown that you don't even know
it's there.
That's something that is really,
really shocking if you ever encounter
it,
and it's the sort of thing that you're
exposed to.
hypothetically whenever you go to a
horror movie that depends on fear,
right?
Because horror movies that depending on
fear,
confront you with things that do not
behave the way they're supposed to
behave.
Like inanimate objects that move.
you know,
if all of a sudden you discover an
inanimate object that moves,
there's a lot that's wrong with your
particular model of the world and you
can kind of experienced that in a horror
movie because things will do things
they're not supposed to do,
like walls will bleed.
That's just not supposed to happen.
And so it's very upsetting to see
something like that.
But you're exposing yourself to that in
horror movies and trying to.
well,
you're trying to develop some courage
because god only knows which of your
fundamental major assumptions.
Mit might just turn it off
to be wrong.
So we talked about representations of
the absolute unknown and I suggested
that those are often associated with
serpentine predators.
And then we talked about representations
of culture because like every character
has to contend with culture,
whether it's a fictional character or
you,
you're stuck with it,
you've got your culture and some of
that's positive because here you are,
you can talk,
you can read,
it's warm,
you know,
you've got a bright future ahead of you.
And then it's also,
uh,
it's also a destructive tyrant because
it's ruining the world and all those
things that you already knew about.
And then.
So that's culture.
And then there's nature because you're
stuck with that too.
And there's a benevolent element of
nature that's usually portrayed with
feminine symbols and that's the mother
nature that environmentalist know and
love.
And then there's,
you know,
mother nature that gives your mother
pants or when she's 40.
And that's the downside of mother nature
and you're pretty much stuck with that
too.
Then there's you and there's all the
useful things about you,
the sort of heroic things.
Technically,
you know the parts of you that would be
able to confront the unknown and to
prevail or to confront the tyrannical
part of the culture and prevail.
That's the positive part,
and then there's the negative part which
is the part of you that you know very,
very well,
that's always causing trouble for you
and other people and it doesn't do what
it's supposed to and is resentful and
angry and petty and mean and ignorant
and blind,
and I'm impulsive and rationalizing and
all of these lovely things that people
are more than capable of doing.
Now.
Those are all archetypes and so there
aren't good types because there are
fundamental.
They're the fundamental personalities
that we use to orient ourselves in life.
I guess that's the best way of thinking
about it.
Now what,
when you talked about an archetype,
it's kind of complicated because
sometimes he talks about them as the
instincts and sometimes he talks about
them and his images and sometimes he
talks about them as stories,
but the best way to contend with that is
to understand that there are all of
those at the same time.
So for example,
if you go to a romance,
which is a kind of architectural story,
you go to a romantic comedy,
say that means you know the protagonists
have a love affair,
and it turns out positively romantic
comedy and architectural structure.
Well,
what other the characters do it while
they're driven by instinct,
obviously,
so that's the instinctive level of the
archetype,
and then it's a behavioral pattern
because they're interacting with each
other and it's a story because someone
has selected out the major elements of
the events in the way that would be most
engaging to an audience and portrayed
them.
So the archetype can be all of those
things at the same time,
there's no contradiction.
It just makes it a more complex
phenomenon.
It's best,
again,
to think of it as a personality and
archetype is a personality and an
architectural story is the manner in
which an archetypal personality
manifests itself across time.
And there's lots of archetypal stories,
and I can give you a couple of
fundamental examples.
The fundamental archetype of male
behavior is the dragon story is
confronting the dragon and that's to go
out confront the dragon,
which can be all sorts of things that
can be the absolute unknown.
It can be the negative element of
femininity,
which is a dragon that stops man and
cold all the time.
Um,
and usually what happens as a
consequence is that the person gets a
treasurer or gets a girl.
Okay.
The fundamental female archetype as far
as I've been able to tell,
it's a little harder to track down.
It took me a long time is beauty and the
beast.
And the reason I figured that out,
there's a bunch of reasons,
but only figured it out about two years
ago.
And I thought,
yeah,
of course,
that's it.
I read this book by the guys who guys
who do data analysis at google and it's
called a billion wicked thoughts.
It's quite an interesting book.
And basically what it is,
is a study of search engine behavior.
And you know,
I think about 18,
19 percent of search engine behavior is
sexual in nature.
And so then you might think,
well,
what are men doing and what are women
doing?
Well,
we know what men are doing.
They're looking at pictures of naked
women,
broadly speaking,
what are women doing hot.
They're not looking at pictures of naked
men.
They're reading about sex.
So women's pornography use his literary.
And so I thought,
oh that's interesting.
That makes sense.
Because actually women read more
fiction.
Men by the way,
women are more predisposed to read
fiction.
Women seem to be more interested in
people than in things are very stable.
Cross cultural,
gender difference anyways,
so women are are reading about sex and
you know that if you buy,
if you look at when I was a kid and I'm
on holidays,
summer holidays,
my mom used to pack her a long,
like 30 harlequin romances.
do you know what a harlequin romances.
Does everybody know what a harlequin
romances does?
Anybody not know?
Okay.
Most people know it's a cheap pulp.
Romance,
you know,
it's like deserving young women meets
dashing and somewhat distant guy.
And then he's already with someone but
she doesn't deserve him.
And then she turns him.
And then,
you know,
he decides that she's actually the one
and then he gets that she gets to have
him and then everyone lives happily ever
after.
So that's a harlequin romance.
Now the original harlequin romances,
they published millions of these bloody
things was just that.
And it was pretty plain,
you know,
g rated story.
But since the seventies harlequin has
exploded and it's gone from,
you know,
g rated stories of disorder I told you
to like triple x version and they're all
very popular and those sorts of stories
also reflected in female use of the
internet.
And so what you see is that they looked
at beauty and the beast stories and
there's five major protagonists and this
is something I think is so absolutely
critical.
It just killed me when I first read it.
Here's the five major guys in female x
rated pornography.
Okay.
We're wolf.
Yeah,
vampire.
yeah.
Surgeon.
Yeah.
Billionaire pirate.
So isn't that funny man?
It just blew me over.
But you know,
it's not much different in some sense
than the male archetypal story of
confronting the drag.
Right?
Because,
and I'll show you something from
sleeping beauty that makes this very
clear what I'll show you that today,
because you know,
if you think about it,
so these are kind of bad guys,
while the world will fund the vampire in
particular,
right?
But there's the pirate up there too,
and you might think,
well,
why would men like that figure in
women's archetipal sexual narratives?
and the answer to that is,
well,
what the hell good is a man who can't be
dangerous,
right?
You think about that and you know,
this bloody theme is played out in
romantic comedies all the time.
Think about there's,
there's the girl and she has a friend,
he's a guy,
he's kind of a guy that never grew up.
He's usually say,
what's his name?
There's a comedian,
seth rogan.
He's usually seth rogen,
you know,
and he's kind of jovial,
nice,
kind of funny and he's your friend,
but he really wants to sleep with her
and she knows that.
So she knows that he's not just her
friend and he isn't just her friend.
He just likes to pretend that you know.
And then there's the guy that she's
interested in who's not like seth rogen
and he's got an edge to him,
you know,
and then the story is usually,
well it plays out.
There's an interpLay between those three
characters and you know,
the seth rogen always going,
well why doesn't she like me?
And the answer is,
well you just watch them for 10 minutes
and you know why?
Partly because she doesn't want a
friend.
she wants someone who's good for
something and someone who's good for
something is someone who's got a
powerful edge.
And part of what happens in the,
in the female archetype is that the
female civilized is that at least in
relationship to herself.
Okay.
So
and then,
well,
and then as far as I'm concerned,
that's not much different,
as I said already in the male hero myth.
So I'm going to show you first,
I'm going to show you something from
sleeping beauty.
So let me just find it here.
What's the universal video player?
Vlc.
Yeah.
That's the one thing.
So I got it downloaded because,
well these,
they stripped this machine every night
and so you have to always download
things over and over.
So.
Okay,
so let's talk about the structure of
sleeping beauty for a minute.
So there's a king and queen and uh,
you know,
they live in a kingdom last logically
enough and they're trying to have a baby
and that doesn't work out very well.
And then all of a sudden,
you know,
after time passes they have this baby
girl and her name is aurora.
So that sort of a reference to the sky
obviously.
Right.
And you often see with archetypical
characters that are affiliated in some
sense with cosmic phenomena.
So for example,
you know,
kings and queens have plans,
right?
And then
divine figures have halos.
Well there's not much difference between
a kate,
a crown and a halo,
and the crown is the sun.
There's a little points on it.
Those are the rays of the sun or the
moon.
It depends on whether the crown is made
out of gold or silver because gold is a
solar metal and silver is a lunar metal.
And so when something is associated with
the cosmos,
that means that it's gone from the
spirit purely personal to the,
to the,
to the impersonal or the transpersonal
or the architectural and archetipal
wouldn't be not your father,
but the father as such,
like the spirit of the father,
not your mother,
but the spirit of the mother as such.
And so when you have the king and the
queen,
you have the sun and the moon.
You have the ruler of the night day
scar,
the ruler of the night sky.
You are the ruler over everything that
the light touches.
And you have the transpersonal fingers
of mother and father.
Okay?
So now you see this in lots of
movies and hero stories in comic books.
So the most commonly portrayed pattern
is that the hero has two sets of
parents,
right?
Harry potter,
he's got the dursleys and they make them
live under the staircase.
And then he has his brother,
cousin.
What's his name?
What's that?
Dudley?
Yeah,
yeah,
yes.
The loan version of doug douglas.
And you know,
he's a bad brother.
So they're actually the argument.
Hostile brothers,
Harry Potter,
hero in adversary,
and then he's got his ordinary parents
and those are the parents that,
well,
they're real ordinary.
They live in an english suburb and
they're extraordinarily conservative,
narrow minded.
They don't want anything to do with
anything magic whatsoever.
And then he has his heavenly parents who
are his magic parents,
right?
And they come back and spirit for them
now and then throughout the movie when
he really needs them.
So superman go to his earthy parents in
his heavenly parents,
right?
If you go into onto wikipedia and you
look up orphan hero,
I think they have a hundred and 60 of
them listed,
so same motif over and over.
And the reason for that is,
well first of all,
when you're a teenager,
one thing you think are,
is,
are these really my parents?
Right?
And so an answer to that is yes and no.
And it's yes in that.
Well obviously from a strict
immediate biological perspective,
they're your parents,
but from an architectural perspective
it's like,
well
you have parents going back three and a
half billion years.
Your parents or just the latest in a
very,
very long line of parents and so the
reason you call your father,
dad or father,
whatever you happen to call them is
because it's in recognition of the fact
that the role you,
the relationship with you do you have
with him to some degree isn't personal.
It's Archetipal.
He's the father.
He plays that role for you and you know,
you can even tell them when he's playing
in property because you might tell your
friends,
you know,
my,
I don't have a very good father.
It's like,
well,
how the hell do you know that,
you know,
it started like you've got this idea in
your mind about what a good father would
be like and if he's not doing that then
it's not him,
you know,
subject to your teenage and childhood
misinterpretations.
And you know,
I have an awful mother all compared to
what?
Well,
compared to the ideal mother,
while you might say,
well just who is this ideal mother?
Well,
you can see her in religious
representations all the time.
So in christianity for example,
you see you're represented as the virgin
mary who is the perfect mother and
that's why she's a holy figure and she's
a holy figure apartment,
archetypical figure,
let's say,
because any society that doesn't worship
the mother and the infant dies,
it has to be sacred because everybody
starts,
everyone has that relationship and if
the society doesn't support it properly
and value it properly,
then well then there's something
seriously wrong with this society.
So
now sleeping duty,
king and queen baby.
okay.
So we've got the.
We've got the familial trial going
there.
So then they decided they're going to
chrisner they're going to name her,
not sort of when she becomes an
individual and they make a mistake when
they're going to christener.
What's the mistake you remember?
How many of you have seen sleeping
beauty?
Yes.
And how many of you have it?
Okay.
So
of those who haven't,
have you seen other disney movies?
Have you seen other disney movies?
Lion king.
Okay.
Anything other than that?
Is there anybody here who's never seen
an animated disney disney movie?
Okay.
Well,
so you see how densely there wasn't
anyone as far as I can tell.
You see how densely distributed
throughout the culture those stories
are,
you know,
even though they,
they're very,
very old stories,
but even in a movie for them,
they're quite old for movies.
Okay.
So the mistake they make is they don't
invite the evil queen to the
christening.
That's a multifacet.
But obviously there's the dot tannic
undertone to that and you know that
she's got these black horns that she
wears,
like she's got this kate that's
basically on fire.
I mean,
you can tell that she's an evil person
and so she's an archetype.
She's the,
she's the archetype of the negative
feminine actually.
And it's a very,
very smart story.
You think,
well,
why would you invite something like that
to your daughter's christening?
Especially if you'd been waiting for her
forever.
And she's a real princess and
everything's perfect.
It's like,
okay,
here's another story.
So as another archetypal story.
So there's these kids and their mother
gets their father,
I think it's divorced,
separates or his wife dies or whatever.
And so he picks up with this new woman
and she decides she doesn't really like
these kids very much.
And that happens a lot by the way.
So if you have a step parent,
you are 100 times more likely to be
physically abused.
So it's the biggest single risk factors
up there with having a drunk parent.
So anyways,
nasty little statistic.
no,
it's hard enough to tolerate kids,
but when there's someone else's kids
that it makes it even more difficult and
that's a friday and observation and it's
no joke and people are not that friendly
and there's terrible jealousy.
Like you know,
if a,
if a man and a woman started going out
and the woman has children and the man
is jealous and the children get in the
way,
especially if they also bother him
because maybe they're not that happy
that he's not actually their father.
Maybe he's just a creep for,
you know,
you never know.
Well,
the tension that can build up in a
situation like that can rapidly become
absolutely unbearable.
it can last forever.
So anyways,
so she tells her new husband,
take those damn kids out in the bush and
see if you could lose them and so he's
not very happy with this,
but I guess he's wrapped around the
finger of his new wife and not very
bright and kind of evil on his own.
So he takes the children out into the
forest and leaves them there and so this
is kind of hard on the children's.
They're out in the wilderness,
which is maybe how you feel when your
mother dies and you know your father
goes and marries a woman,
you're out in the bloody wilderness and
they get lost and then they're lost and
they're all freaked out because they're
lost and they're going to starve and
wolves are going to eat them because
this is like medieval europe forest and
it's full of wolves and the people and
so
and they're wandering around out there
and they come across a gingerbread
house.
Now if you're a skepTical person and
you're not naive,
the first thing you think is this is too
good to be true.
It's like,
yeah,
house.
Okay,
fine.
A shack maybe,
or even a lean to.
Sure that could happen,
but a house that's also made out of
candy,
it's like,
nah,
there's something going on there that's
not so good.
You know the kind of person that's
really nice to you,
but really isn't your member.
Again,
the Harry Potter series,
remember that woman?
She was a bureaucrat.
Channel those plates of kittens.
Rich delores.
Delores means sad,
right?
Umbrage means to take offense.
So she's the sad woman who takes a fence
and she got all these pictures of
kittens on her,
on plates right there on ceramic plates.
And so those are like hyper sentimental.
It's like a pewter plates and everything
and we'll put them on our wall and you
know,
it's like really low and taste and the
sentimentality is
a facade.
You would call that a persona of
benevolence,
but remember old dolores umbridge.
She's not exactly your benevolent type.
in fact,
you know,
you let her loose on the world and
horrible things happening.
Um,
what's her name?
The woman who wrote Harry Potter.
She got that exactly right.
It's one of her best characters,
I think.
So she's got that fake voice that you
often hear people who actually don't
like children use when they're talking
to children are the cutest little thing
like you know,
you can actually talk to children and
they actually liked that and then they
don't think that,
you know,
you're possessed by something
that they should run away from as fast
as possible.
Anyways,
so a hansel and greTel,
the woman comes out and she's all nice
and she said,
oh children,
you're lost in the forest.
Why don't you come in and have some
ginger bread?
And so then she puts little pencil in a
cage,
like a bird cage I think.
And she gets gradle to do all the
slavery stuff,
you know,
so she's not so nice.
And then everyday she goes,
she's stuffing on well with gingerbread
and then she goes and feels little hats.
Have legs,
see if he's nice and pumps so that she
can throw them in the stove.
ANita.
And what that means is that beware of
people who are too nice to you because
what they're trying to do is devour you.
And it's the prime dictum of freudian
psychopathology.
If you have a parent now,
freud concentrated mostly on mothers
because mothers are more likely to do
this because for a variety of reasons
that we're not going to talk about
probably because they are oriented
towards babies,
but whatever.
If you're too nice to your child and you
do everything for them,
what happens to them?
Well then they can't do anything for
themselves.
And so then what happens?
Well then they live in your basement
till they're 50,
you know,
and then they get irritated one day and
they shoot up dawson college.
So there's a deep metaphor in the story
and the story is if it's too damn good
to be true,
it's probably aiming at your
destruction.
Okay.
Now back to sleeping beauty.
So sleeping beauty,
aurora is going to be christened and
they decided not to invite the evil
queen to the christening.
Now that's not a very good idea.
One time I had,
this is a composite client,
so this person,
all she wanted to do with sleep,
so she'd sleep like 16,
17 hours a day and she was doing that
partly sleeping pills because it's hard
to sleep that much.
But left her own devices,
she would just sleep.
Now you might say,
well why would someone want to do that?
And then you could say,
well,
for the same reason that people drink
themselves into unconsciousness and
oblivion,
which is like,
it's painful to be conscious,
especially when your life isn't going
that well,
maybe you're afraid of things.
And so why be awakened suffered,
wouldn't even be unconscious and not
suffer.
And so that was basically her idea and
she was,
she was a vegetarian,
um,
and she was terrified of butcher shops
and she was terrified of raw meat and
that was logical because she was sort of
terrified of life.
And if you're going to be terrified of
life,
you really think about,
it's the whole bloody raw meat part of
life that you're more or less terrified
by it.
So that was very concretized in her
situation.
And so I used to take her to
supermarkets through the raw meat
section because that's what you do in
psychotherapy in case any of you want
psychotherapy,
you have to do the thing you least want
to do.
And so that's not particularly fun.
that's the gateway to enlightenment.
You walked through the gate where you
least wanted,
well,
so now you know why people aren't
enlightened because it's not all fun and
games and follow your bliss and all that
nonsense.
It's like figure out what you're afraid
of and avoiding and confronted
voluntarily.
So anyways,
I got a little background from her and
her mother who I met,
who is definitely the evil queen.
I mean she yelled at me for like 45
minutes in my office.
It was really quite remarkable.
I hadn't had anyone.
I've only had one other person yelled at
me in my office ever and she was also
definitely an evil queen,
but this woman,
she was just something else like it was
just jaw dropping to watch her perform.
And she used to phone up my client all
the time,
three or four times a day and tell her
how stupid and useless she was.
And so if you,
if you have parents that phone you up
every day and tell you how stupid and
useless you are,
then it's perfectly within your rights
to not talk to them because that's what
they should be telling you.
So then you can say,
well how about if I call you instead of
you calling me?
And how about if it's once every two
weeks instead of three times a day?
And how about if you say anything nasty,
I just hang up and then I don't talk to
you for a month.
And then you might say,
well I couldn't do that to my mother.
And then I would say,
well that's because she already won.
So anyways,
this girl,
her mother loved her to death when she
was little,
she was perfect.
She was a princess when she was little.
But then of course you hit puberty,
you know,
and then that's the end of the whole
princess thing because then of course
you want to go out and have a life and
maybe you know,
associate with boys and do all that sort
of thing.
That's not the least bit child princess
light.
And that's when everything broke down
and started to go in a very,
very bad direction and that was partly
because her mom didn't want to invite
the evil queen to her little daughter's
life because the evil queen is the
negative part of nature.
And like if you,
if you have a little girl,
well the probability that she's going to
grow up and be a teenager and then a
woman is pretty high unless you do
something to seriously interfere with
that which you might.
And so you bloody well better be
prepared for that when she's three and
not treat her like she's someone whose
feet are never going to touch the earth.
You have to have the whole element of
life in there.
Right.
I had another client,
her parents taught her that adults were
angels and I don't mean metaphorically.
They actually taught her that and in
doing so,
they set her up for serious
posttraumatic stress disorder,
which she had for about five years
because she ran into someone who wasn't
an angel.
Surprise,
surprise.
And all he did do her roughly speaking,
was looking at her like he wanted to
kill her.
And you think,
well,
nobody could be traumatized like that.
It's like,
well,
hey,
probably no one's ever looked at you
like that,
so don't be so sure.
But b,
if they did look at you like that and
you thought that adults were angels,
then you were pretty much nicely set up
to have posttraumatic stress disorder.
So anyways,
you might think that you're doing your
children a big favor by keeping the evil
queen out if their nursery,
but you know,
you might let them see a glimpse of her
now and then so they can get used to the
fact that she exists.
You know?
And I guess that's why children have
pets and part,
right?
Because like mike's,
they don't last very long.
So you have a live mouse for awhile and
then you have a dead mouse and that's
not very good.
But then there's some things that you
get accustomed to while you're doing
that.
And maybe it's not so good to protect
your children from that because they're
going to have to grow up and survive in
the awful world.
And your job isn't to make them happy.
Your job is to make them able to survive
in the nasty real world anyways.
okay,
so that's what happens with sleeping
beauty at the beginning.
It's like hansel and gretel and then
evil queen shows up anyways because good
luck keeping her out of your house.
and she basically says,
yeah,
well that's all well and good.
I'm,
you know,
there's nothing I can do about it,
but come puberty roughly,
and the sleeping beauty,
she,
she's going to prick your finger on a
needle on a spinning wheel.
So there's blood involved there so we
don't have to use our imagination too
much to imagine what that means.
It's like I'm gonna,
come back and then,
oh,
hell's gonna break loose.
And of course then the parents really
protect her,
which is exactly the wrong thing to do
and well,
that's the sleeping beauty story.
Of course,
the prince comes along and he eventually
figures out how to solve this problem,
right?
She needs him.
He's a pretty good guy.
Then evil queen puts him in a dungeon.
It's like her basement and then she's
going to keep them.
They're telling you so old that he can't
even ride and he's,
she's going to laugh at him as he tries
to leave and then he tries to leave and
she turns into a dragon.
It's like,
what the hell?
Why?
Why is she turning into a drag?
But you accept that no problem.
Steve mcqueen turns into a dragon.
What else would you do?
And then she spoke fire him and he
fights are off.
And then he has to hack his way through
all the forums and thistles that have
gathered around the castle.
And then he wakes the girl up and the
fountains come back on and everyone's
happy and you all think that's an
excellent story.
So,
and it is an excellent story,
but it's a weird story because it's an
archetypal story and you understand it
at an architectural level.
I mean,
let me show you some of it.
and then,
uh,
I'll talk a little bit more about it.
So
let's look at the beginning to begin
with.
So.
Oh yeah,
sorry.
This is,
this is a class.
So I don't want you to actually enjoy
the movie.
So I'm going to play around with.
Okay.
So tell me about the book.
Is it a valuable book or not?
How do you know?
Hey,
it's covered with gold and jewels for
what you're getting right there.
There's something valuable about this.
So your property.
Yeah,
I guess.
it's a valuable book.
Got gold and jewels.
Why or why is gold valuable?
It's rare.
Yeah.
It's like the sun looks like the sun.
What else?
If it's morally pure gold,
why?
Because if it does,
well it is wealthy.
Even it's morally pure because it won't
mix with other metals that doesn't meet
with other metals.
It's imperishable and it doesn't
tarnish.
So it's a symbol of purity and jewels.
Why are,
why are they beautiful?
Invaluable.
Forget about rare.
Shining.
Yeah,
they're shiny.
But even chros can appreciate that.
So like what is shiny have to do with
it?
Do you think john sign?
Yeah.
Reflects light.
Right?
So what do you want a good person to do?
Well,
maybe you might say that.
Yeah.
I think they reflect light.
And the reason it's interesting because
the reason that crystal's how are the
way they are translucent can reflect
light is because their internal
structure or crystal is a lattice of
molecules and then that loudness is
precisely replicated everywhere in the
crystal.
So it's one thing all the way down to
the molecular level.
And so one of the things that you might
think is that if,
especially if you think about that
hierarchical model that we were talking
about,
is that if you were as well put together
as you could be and had maybe been
subject to the right amount of heat and
pressure,
that you would be the same thing at
every single level of being.
And then you'd Be solid and crystalline
and you would reflect light.
and so.
So anyways,
you get a hit right off the bat that
this is.
That this story is valuable
in a far away land
is hysterically many years have they own
for child fun,
which was granted.
A doctor was for they call her
yes,
named her,
asked her for.
She filled their lives with sunshine.
Then a great holiday was proclaimed
throughout the kingdom.
So that all of high or low state might
pay homage to the infant princess.
Our story is one of the most joyful day,
good
stephens
to her going to use future.
So these are
the
elements of the feminine
and they give her various gifts
and
ramble.
Quite distressed about receiving an
invitation.
All right,
well we're out of time.
I'll show you a bunch more this next
next class and we'll see what it means.